First up-- squad goals.
You know, it can be so hard
for today's politicians
to connect with millennials,
especially for Machiavellian
mamaw Hillary Clinton.
That's why she...
That's why she took to young
peoples' social network Snapchat
this week to post a video
of her with some lady pals,
along with the very millennial
caption, "This squad."
-(laughter)
-Mm.
Oh. Well...
(breathlessly): "Everyone...
this... yes, indeed,
"my squadron is on fleek, okay?
-Ha, ha."
-(laughter)
"Stay on target.
"Okay, everyone pick a color
from the color wheel,
and let's make
those tops happen."
(laughter)
Comedians,
what are This Squad's goals?
Jenny.
-Beating osteoporosis.
-(laughter)
HARDWICK:
Yes. Points.
-Points.
-(laughter, applause)
Mm-hmm.
-Chris Garcia. -Green-lighting
a fourth Bridget Jones movie.
-HARDWICK: Yes. Points.
-(laughter, applause)
-It needs to happen.
-Yes.
Jordan Morris.
Uh, what's This Squad's goal,
Chris?
To pound Chardonnay,
do tons of blow
and stay up till 4:00 a.m.
syncing each other's periods.
HARDWICK: All right, yes.
All right, points.
-(laughter)
-Points, yes.
-(applause and cheering)
-I'm just gonna say, none of 'em
-are gonna have had their period
for, like, 15 years. -Yeah.
-At least.
-Jordan. -Yeah.
-(applause and cheering)
-All right?
Figure out how a vagina works,
okay?
-HARDWICK: Yeah, Jordan.
-I should...
Yeah, there ain't no eggs
in that basket. Yeah.
-Just saying.
-(laughter)